on a fait une autre proposition pour les
retraites parce que le projet qui nous
est proposée par la majorité n'est pas
le bon il n'est pas le bon parce que il
n'est pas financé
il ne résout pas les problèmes il
compromet toutes les réserves qui n'ont
pas coûté un euro d'argent public ou aux
contribuables des indépendants des
professions libérales et il ne n'assure
pas durablement le financement
nécessaire à la pérennité du régime par
répartition le gouvernement le président
de la république a été au final mans
c'est piéger tout seul avec la promesse
de ne pas reporter l'âge de départ à la
retraite
or on sait que la seule façon de peser
sur le financement celle c'est une
mesure d'âge une vraie mesure d'âge